monsieur monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à Madame
s'adresser à madame la ministre délégué
chargé des collectivités territoriales
l'article 72 de la Constitution garantit
la libre administration des
collectivités territoriales et donc des
communes cellules de base de la
démocratie mais vu dans l'eau les
communes ne seraient qu'un échelon
administratif alors que dans les faits
on les a vu pendant la crise du covid
les communes et leurs élus se trouvent
ont été les plus proches de nos
concitoyens en première ligne or à quoi
assiste ton depuis plusieurs années à
une véritable mise sous tutelle des mers
qui sous couvert de soi-disant loi de
décentralisation ne dispose plus
d'aucune autonomie fiscale l'État a
progressivement supprimé les impôts
locaux dans les communes fixées
librement le taux pour les remplacer par
des rotation et des impôts nationaux
partagés et que dire des fameux contrats
de Cahors et du soi-disant pacte de
confiance que le gouvernement veut
imposer à toute force comme le constate
l'économiste Michel cabanes la garantie
constitutionnelle de l'autonomie
financière n'est plus qu'une façade et
comme le dit Philippe Laurent
vice-président de la MF ce que veut
l'État au fond c'est la suppression de
la fiscalité locale ce que les mœurs les
mers peuvent retenir eux c'est que ce
jacobinisme cette recentralisation de
moins en moins déguisé des notes le peu
de considération que l'État pour eux et
le mépris dans lequel les tient quand le
gouvernement se décidera-t-il
entreprendre une vraie réforme fiscale
qui redonnera dignité confiance aux
maires premiers élus du peuple
[Applaudissements]